Hello Freak bitches.
I'm doing everything I can do possibly a
cryo machine.
Um,
you name a hyperbaric chamber.
Everything I could do,
I'm looking for the edge because
everyone's,
they get,
they got a champ.
I'm,
I'm broke.
They got money.
They.
So imagine what they got and now I'm
scrambling to get everything I could
get.
You know what I need to get to the next
level.
I know,
I see it,
I see it.
Any man and I'm me,
like many other people rooting for you.
Thank you.
Oh,
just,
it's frustrating when I see you getting
close to these fights with guys like
David Hay and then it falls apart to
sucker.
What happened when they said he was
going to fight you?
I went over to England champion.
They showed me nothing but love.
They seen the true character of who he
really is.
He ain't really a good dude,
man.
He's not a,
he's a businessman,
but he's also like a,
you know,
he's a,
he's a weird dude man.
You know what I mean?
You,
I shook his hand.
We said we had a goal because be
grateful,
great fight,
win,
lose or draw for either one of us.
Um,
and everything was set and he did
everything they needed me to do and then
he just did the,
uh,
he felt he was looking for another deal.
And the truth of the matter is,
I heard this from the inside that he was
like,
it's too dangerous,
you know,
that's just the bottom line,
which is what they often.
He's a fairly small heavyweight.
Y'All smash them up.
That was an easy one for me.
That was a layup.
I was like,
oh,
look at him on one smashed.
And he was scared.
A little steam in his eyes.
I'm from Brownsville.
I got one thing I can smell when you're,
when you're scared.
I'm from the same neighborhood as Mike
Tyson.
Ready Paul?
I know.
When the man scared,
I went up on him.
Joe.
I looked in his eyes.
I seen his lips.
He was trembling.
He was scared.
I could smell it.
I'll be like,
oh,
this is a layup layup champ.
This is an easy one,
champ.
Yeah.
What does he wait?
He's not a,
it's not only a heavy guy.
I had that one child.
I could see me just snatching them
Vegan.
I'm eating bowls and cows and all
dinosaurs.
Straight animal for you.
There's a lot of momentum in your side.
It's just a matter of getting a fight
signed.
The heavyweight division right now,
it's pretty exciting.
It's not in the face done the big
fights,
but I'm just saying for,
for Brown,
those people to try to act like they
had,
they were going to grab the bull by the
Horn and not be able to come with a
deal.
You know,
they had to.
I think they have a couple of days until
we go to bed.
Like if that was the case that we should
have just went the purse.
But I'm ready now.
I'm ready now.
I don't want no more delays.
I don't want to play with this boy.
Another boy.
Don't want to pay with this man.
This young man with a family.
I don't want to play with him.
I want the bellarine because he and my
way up.
I understand,
but he's in my way and it's nothing like
people don't want to stand like you
could call me crazy,
but that's what.
That's okay.
Look,
I my mind and my mind.
This is like a already written destiny.
I was allowed of shape.
I was dealt and now I wanted to kill
myself and now I came back with nothing
behind me,
but the people,
the people's chairs,
everywhere I go,
he's in my way.
He's just like a tornado come and he's a
role.
I'm a terrible part.
He just said my weight because I got a
bigger picture champion all the belts I
want to people around the world,
all the belts chair.
I want people all around the world and
be like,
Yo,
here's my story.
I got to.
I don't have a great record.
I've got like six or seven months,
five,
six months.
Who knows?
I had ups and downs.
I've never been considered a great,
but I fought guys who will tell you on
the low man,
he get busy.
Excellent.
Is Louis.
They'll tell you guys who,
who,
who know me or who,
who boxing acts.
Chris Bird.
They say,
you know what,
Shannon never read that.
Never really seen Shannon.
They never really seen Shannon.
I'm honest.
I'm not.
I'm,
I'm keeping it real.
I ain't never seen me.
They going to see me win this fight.
Get done.
They're going to see me.
They gonna see the real shit.
They going to say,
wow,
we didn't know he had a lot of talent.
We didn't know.
Let's go chat,
chat.
They won't see it for real.
This is a lot of suffering.
Pain Champ and a lot of love too because
they're all around the world.
They see them.
Let's go champion.
They feel in the positivity and they
said,
you know what jam we behind you man.
The people should.
That's not happening in boxing champ and
that's,
and that is another reason that's
fueling me to look at the box and you
look at the state of the heavyweight
division.
It was flat before me,
champ.
Couldn't go,
was doing nothing was sticking up
division for gears.
Grab whole,
grab,
hold.
Come on.
Champion.
Heavyweight champion of the world.
You're supposed to be the biggest
project.
Sports.
You're supposed to be out there doing
interviews.
You're supposed to be Muhammad Ali here
to stay around people around kids around
the world,
supposed to know that they had,
which had been the world when I was out
there trying to campaign and even to
this day,
you ask somebody who's the head we're
championing rural.
They don't even know.
Nobody knew.
Nobody knows now.
And he was a white guy.
Yeah,
but ask them now who's they don't even
know.
Nobody knows.
Now you go around and I keep people call
me one thing,
champ.
Yeah.
They say chat when you're fighting.
Exactly.
So that's what I.
that's what I'm talking about.
Bringing back the imagery to the game.